[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les voit très bien joué
je suis
révélations
robin
[Musique]
musique
[Applaudissements]
ça
tu
[Applaudissements]
2h06
j'ai eu un pote de luxe et mon fiancé
est ce que tu es hier
ça arrivait
howard-tripp a passé la barre des 2
millions et envoie deux jours non c'est
vrai qu'on est champions donc café
bouillant
l'athée macchiato l'ex jacent sucre
quand est-ce que tu as publié le dernier
tweet il ya deux heures non son scoot
ravenaux martenet
[Musique]
cet égard
m
[Musique]
ouais cette chanson sera l'une des
mélodies principal de la comédie
musicale où le public sera submerger par
ses émotions voilà
et tout ça ce n'est qu'un petit aperçu
de l'ascenseur émotionnel auquel les
gens seront soumis pendant l'ascension
puis la chute de phoenix la brave et
courageuse dresseuse de dragon ou la
traversée du mur de feu
game of thrones rencontre enger games
avec une légère touche de twilight écrit
et dirigé par youri tacen voilà qui a
préparé la chanson il est temps de
commencer les auditions
[Musique]
on soumet koba
1 2 lille j'aimerais vraiment pouvoir
jouer quelques chansons en acoustique
non écoute on vient juste de finir de
créer ton propre style ton truc à toi
c'est la pop oublie un peu tes
compositions
tu peux pas passer de l'un à l'autre
comme ça notre choix carrière
c'est énorme ce serait aussi formé de
terrain wendy nicklin minima d écouter
quand on espère d'autres mais ouais deux
autres tel film home est encore spider
de mai suivant
au suivant
j'aurais
[Musique]
vous
au suivant à l'arbre oui il ya quatre
heures dans l'histoire je sais mais ils
ont ni tête ni chanson désolé aimerait
bien faire un arbre mettez une de mes
meilleures chanteuses et écoutez c'est
pas sa faute
non c'est eux la comédie musicale c'est
pas son style et une chanson de boule à
facettes ça aide pas non plus va pour un
arbre yorick t elle sur quel genre d'apt
envie d'être un boulot un chêne sapin de
noël c'est bon alors tu couches monsieur
scrutin pour des menaces identifiées son
personnage jégo la facem et je suis sur
tout
[Musique]
désolé petites gens oui
tu vas bien
ouais
je m'éclate comme tu peux voir
oui
[Musique]
est ce que tu es blessé
oui oui tout va bien ouais laisse-nous
trame de chez toi non désolé impossible
on est déjà bien trop porta si on
commence à faire ce genre de choses
toutes tes fans vont se jeter sous plus
dans ce cas je te faut des places pour
mon concert au premier un pardon mais tu
fais un peu peut en voir
non mais y toi tu t'es vu monsieur boule
à facettes tout ce que je veux c'est un
nouveau vélo je te retrouverai un oui je
m'en occuperai allez retourne dans le
bus tu vas attraper la mort et ça c'est
pour toi
rendez vous demain à 16h à cette adresse
non mais quelle aventure qu'est ce que
c'est que ça qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
encore claque pas la porte comme ça
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je me suis
fait renverser comme commença à temps
montre moi ta maman c'est bon c'est rien
au regard
mappus faut nettoyer ça avance assez
infects aller dans quoi tu t'es fichu
rien du tout zaug tu es blessé est en
vélo est cassé aïe quoi aller raconte
moi j'ai été renversé par boule à
facettes par qui la regardent jouer ça
suffit dit moi la vérité c'est la vérité
a bien vu l'état de mon vélo avec donc
tu étais pas au téléphone messagerie
quand amour tout le monde a sa chance
jouer tu écoute parce que je te dis
combien de fois je t'ai demandé mais bon
j'ai cours grabels où tu fais quoi rien
j'essaie de vendre des trucs sur
internet quoi
ce sont pas tes affaires écoute ton père
avait six mois pour venir les chercher
s'il n'est pas venu s'il s'en fiche
d'accord
[Musique]
mon pote matt moi ça ouais je l'avais la
taille de ses confrères lors tout
s'enchaîne paraguay c'est incroyable et
pourquoi on est là au juste eh bien nous
sommes venus pour rencontrer le grand
patron mesdames messieurs je vous
remercie rien l'auteur pour ce prix
incroyables je voudrais enfin le grand
milieu ravi de rencontrer en personne
franck steen weezer bonjour alias tonnes
ars
tu vois bah ouais bien sûr cela ne
relance pas payer vous je vous écoute
nick je n'en avais pas parlé pour
l'instant mais ça fait un moment que
frank et moi on est en contact et je
crois que c'est très prometteur ce qui
se passe c'est que franck aimerait
qu'ils signent avec sa maison de disques
d'après les liens ne ce serait génial
pour ta carrière et usec ne travaille
qu'avec les meilleurs
voici le contraire tout ce que tu as à
faire c'est signé et en moins de deux
tours a le monde à ses pieds
frank et moi avons négocié tous les
détails
quoi qu'elles détaillent vous lui avez
pas encore dit mik
tu es bien assez
l'amérique mongrain
m le state c'est le paradis des rappeurs
oui d'ailleurs lui c'est djédjé c'est
lui qui gère tous nos réseaux sociaux
ils t'ont tubes des cafés aussi bien sûr
alors ce sera trois cafés au nom tu sais
quoi va pas chercher le sont pas le
titre mais tu sais que j'avais prévu de
rentrer chez mes parents à curation pour
terminer l'album est maintenant c'est
plus la peine
franck a fait écrire ton tout nouvel
album par des auteurs compositeurs
américains
du coup tout est déjà prévu mais en
anglais ça aussi c'est un choix de
carrière mais disons que si tu es amené
à traverser tous les états unis ce
serait mieux qu'ils chantent en anglais
[Rires]
mais tu mais je vois que vous avez déjà
fait de la place pour mes récompense
[Rires]
bonjour à tous et à toutes c'est avec
joie que je vous souhaite aujourd'hui la
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle émission
de france est wissam et est aujourd'hui
nous accueillons une superstar
c'est vraiment là et aujourd'hui je vous
demande d'accueillir le grand mix
bienvenue mitch scène fait plaisir à
voir aussi bien mieux au studio c'est
parti c'est ce qui a été tiré deux des
plus grandes fans de milk sont sur le
point de s'affronter lors de
l'impitoyable quiz de la douche
ne zappez par lé hulu participantes
elle a trois minutes de retard ça c'est
ton boulot pagnon
quelqu'un avait désiré on est censé dire
quoi j'ai pas qu'on est venu pour le
vélo mais ouais bien sûr c'est l'unique
le super star oui son vélo ça
fonctionnera jamais et d'ailleurs il a
fait oublier et non ceux rapportés pour
rien au pire tu as qu'à tester une autre
entrée désirer
désiré ya quelqu'un
enfin certains d'entre eux oui c'est
bonjour et allez vous fuyez au
maquillage à mairie
attendez je savais qu'elle allait à
tétouan tube love un retour à moi tout
ça oui oui on arrive ça y est
un très bon
ouais bon tout
c'est parti
voilà ma place aller là-bas d'accordéon
fait quoi l'adage fonctionnaires chaises
longues la bleue elle est pour toi bonne
chance aux jeunes touchent surtout soit
jolie d'attention ces quartiers
on lance la musique on y va
nous revoilà d'emprunter douche avec
aujourd'hui encore nous accueillons deux
superstars sur notre plateau chez nommé
mai et maintenant découvrons les fans de
mix askia et désirez vous êtes contente
d'être parmi eux un peu nerveuse allez
bonne chance fait partie
découvrons qu'ils ont c'est le plus sûr
la fille de mick et qui aura droit exact
que de plus comment ce qu'elle est le
signe de mick a selon l'astrologie
chinoise li cèdre c'est une bonne
réponse depuis combien de temps les
parents de milly fti la cuirasse aux dix
mois et c'est encore 3 ça doit pas être
facile
la meilleure amie de ma mère et mon
manager donc c'est un peu comme être
famille tes parents te manque et c'est
l'important c'est pas la fréquence à
laquelle on se voit je les porte dans
mon coeur donc c'est comme si on était
toujours ensemble
ou attendre le sommet il faut faire des
sacrifices pour atteindre le sommet il
faut faire des sacrifices
voilà qui est bien dit les portiers
n'ont qu'une seule chose à faire
issel ouvrir la porte et est quelqu'un
qui frappe tu peux m'expliquer en quoi
c'est compliqué c'est pas moi le portier
moi je suis meilleur pote de mick et je
suis un futur rappeur c'est mon meilleur
pote c'est miley cyrus elle même après
at work et un témoin qui nous voient
king of working all black mic mac n'est
pas une piste très technique avec la
crème chantilly
des unités du cyclo madame evelyne à
l'école primaire la chanson sur le line
up and drive
[Musique]
football breaking au génial à lady diana
et c'est d'y mettre un peu du sien c'est
un zoo et bien quand il avait 4 ans
micka vu un costume dans un magasin de
déguisements
il a ensuite su oublier sa mère de lui
acheter ce déguisement
de quoi s'agit sétif désirer oh oui oui
dans les airs d'un pingouin seule elle
était pourtant facile non pas guanghua
c'est une nouvelle pendant les quatre
ans askia qui remporte donc ce quiz
non c'est la douche
[Musique]
quel dommage que j'irai au vif
elle s'appelle the way up quel dommage
dos et il est temps que tu nous quittes
mais à partir d'aujourd'hui tu pourras
t'en dormir avec nick
on en sait plus où elle prend ta couette
et vatan tu fais pas partie de mes fans
même si ça t'étonne ya des gens qui
t'aiment pas non tout ce que je voulais
dire c'est que dans ce cas c'est bizarre
de venir participer à un quiz sur ma vie
privée non je suis ni fan de toi ni ta
musique niaise news oui niese saignait
et c'est complètement commercial moi non
plus ça me plaît pas moi ce que je veux
c'est écrire mes textes
à rennes c'est pas drôle
pardon reviens tu as raison ce qui est
stupide mais je lui dis ton vrai nom
ouais je fais non tu veux une médaille
tiens ton oreiller pour y rêve de me
suit partout
je comprends pas pourquoi tu me met dans
des états pareils d'abord tu as détruit
mon vélo et moi on fait tous voulaient
me faire passer pour une imbécile
l'histoire du vélo ce n'était qu'une
excuse pour vous faire venir à lui ton
vélo mais pourtant les lianes indique
enfin que voilà mon nouveau petit
protégé préféré regarde j'ai quelqu'un
de présenter ça je m'appelle kate
christiane aviez les jeux matin italien
lui chanteuse elle a une voix fascinante
et ça ce que je le dis pas parce que
c'est la fille qui part donc une seconde
à l'eau oui j'imagine que tu m'as vu sur
kate soit c'est ma chaîne youtube elle
saison et je suis censé la connaître je
joue un arbre sans texte dans
l'ascension puis la chute de phoenix la
brave et courageuse dresseuse de dragon
ou la traversée du mur de face et des
sujets ça a l'air bien mieux là de
tickets enfin je trouves tu viens celle
y aller c'est bientôt l'heure de la
dernière partie de l'émission croyez
qu'on veut acheter un vélo à souhait oui
oh oui
bien sûr allez viens avec moi et tient
ici qu'à et de kate webb et je suis sûr
que vous connaissez ce garçon à mes
côtés salut tu cela
non désolé pour un tueur tenta prochaine
fois et basse a lu les noms
ma copine est là dedans écoute je sais
pas qu il leur manquerait mais si la
sortie wii et ton cadeau tu peux oublier
ton vélo donc je veux plus te voir dans
quoi merci beaucoup aller et vous
déguerpissez
[Musique]
soit
sowerby
moi
[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir et bienvenue à d'accord qu'est
ce qu'on mange
les pactes bon j'ai bien alors vous
étiez passé où on était un quiz télé
vous étiez un quiz télé et zoé a même
gagné un édredon attend quoi qu'est ce
qui peut arriver quoi plumes de poulet
zoé ouais tu sais que les enfants
t'attendais à l'hôpital ouais je sais je
m'en suis souvenu ce matin la place tu
allais un quiz télé oui mais en fait
c'était pas sa faute on allait là bas et
et puis tout d'un coup on s'est retrouvé
sur le plateau je devais juste récupérer
un vélo hoc et ben ça peut marcher
jouer tu sais parfaitement que j'ai pas
de quoi payer un terrien long des essais
juste deux ans pour s'achever la barre
est dit chez moi on essaie de rester
silencieux pendant le dîner ça vous
dirait pas connaissez bon appétit
souhaites tu sais que ces enfants courte
nuit je sais la ferveur religieuse les
allées c'est pas la peine de rêver tout
un plat à faire là l'enjeu les voyages
et au prix de l'hôpital et on a bien le
groupe via ringard grand rival et
retourne a détruit mon vélo je voulais
juste qu'il me le remplacer tous sauvés
tu peux me donner toutes les eaux
favorisée
désolé maman j'irai demain et échappe
pas cette fois oui je te promets demande
avait prévu d'aller faire du shopping
c'est vrai j'irai dès que j'ai fini
d'accord d'accord allez manger ça va
être froid
et champion tu penses encore la fille
d'hier 1
j'ai bien vu comment tu l'as matin c'est
vrai qu'elle était plutôt canon on
dirait un peu une actrice d'hollywood
elle est toute mince et en même temps
elle a aussi des supers hanche cette
quête allait carrément parfaite à la
kate qu'elle a marqué le hockey c'est
chris qui sont retrouvés comme et c'est
ce week end que t'as rien publier de la
journée et je te retrouves à traîner à
la piscine sa famille qu il faut que tu
sois prêt dans 15 minutes les accords
elle est partie mais c'est lui et moi
c'est nick j'ai une super moustache
d'ebook de reykjanes ans sans oublier
monosourcil et on est tous pas mordre
salut les filles en route pour faire du
lèche vitrine j'imagine pourquoi 900 ça
va
était adorable petite soeur des fois
faut que j'aie secoue un peu pour
qu'elle se taise ouais voilà c'est bon
tu étais nouvelle z'auriez l'attend s'il
te plaît j'aimerais seulement qu'on
discute un peu aller où ils veulent
aller
au pire tu m'envoies tu extra près
d'accord
soler
comment tu vas
ça va
tu joues toujours lé ou marraine de la
guitare
nulle part je pense arrêter zoreil ce
serait stupide tes chansons sont
géniales d'un ton roi les décisions
stupides cette famille
écoute zoé je comprends que tu me
détestes mais c'est pas une raison pour
abandonner ce serait vraiment du gâchis
zoé j'ai pas fini
a été regardée quoi il est mignon c'est
pourquoi notre premier baiser avant ou
après qu'on soit leur crête
moi je vous rencontrez quelqu'un de
spécial ouais bah elle lui est la
spéciale dommage qu'il ait pas un copain
avec lui tu te souviens la règle numéro
2 on doit donner notre premier baiser en
même temps pour ce soir
tu prends le gauche tu prends droite on
veut savoir si non tu comptes pour dire
quoi
j'en sais rien quand comme les embrasser
visite
piste on va finir par les pairs
[Musique]
tiens six mois un autographe au tapis
jadis était carrément canaux sur le pote
de milk
mais qu'est ce qui dit il soutient le
portier juin rappeur mavs futur rappeur
tout compte fait je préférerais un vélo
plutôt qu'un autographe
on passe pas dans tout le monde la
demoiselle
[Musique]
écoute je lis j'ai un paquet fan tu veux
un autographe
tu fais quoi là dégage de là les projets
spéciaux c'est pas toi tu peux voir
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu me suis donne moi ton numéro
pour que je te le donnerai je te connais
même pas ouais mais si tu veux un vélo
va bien falloir que je t'appelle on peut
y aller maintenant il ya une boutique à
côté non elle se mettrait tout à me
réclamer un vélo oh tu fonces dans tous
tes fans et écoute ce vélo c'est pas une
blague pour moi mais vu tomber ça
m'étonne pas que tu comprennes pas
d'accord tu sais quoi c'est moi qui
donne mon numéro
je vais m'occuper de tout meilleurs
d'accord c'est promis
et si je donne ton numéro à tout le
monde c'est pas comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
je connais pas
[Musique]
ma
être voté
est ce vrai que baic mons et gagner des
lots les vendeurs technique amour
on se pose
mais bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les bombarder ni un monstre
t'as quoi de prévu aujourd'hui bonjour
tout le monde je suis la princesse rose
heroes et je me demande où se trouve mon
prince charmant
est-ce que vous en avez vu un nom
[Musique]
bonjour moi je suis le prince boule à
facettes
l'armée est postée le match était belle
et elle le yoga est pris comme si le
plan finot conq toyota est en fait une
bataille
une battle way avant j'étais amoureuse
d'eminem donc j'ai pris des cours de rap
vous savoir aux allées demander la main
votre père ja princesse
rendez vous compte il s'agit tout de
même du roi balthazar vi est oui mais
vous devez prouver votre courage mon
prince le ferez vous pour moi pour vous
je serai prêt à tout princesse rose
heroes mais plus tard car je dois
malheureusement retourner au palais au
revoir les enfants déjà la reine est
très inquiète donc le prince n'est
disponible que cinq minutes avant de
s'enfuir à nouveau ce n'est pas très
gentille princesse
je suis venue spécialement pour vous les
enfants alors que je suis très occupé
oui trop occupé à être adorés par votre
cours de groupe i n'est ce pas c'est
vrai que rendre visite aux enfants
malades est bien moins important que
l'ego de monsieur le prince au revoir
boule à facettes
finalement la reine peut attendre
voilà qui est fort aimable mon prince
la bisou le bisou le bisou le bisou
bisou bisou bisou la vie de la ville où
ça fait mal à la pagaille et by dj wiwi
milk la sécurité ne le trouve nulle part
j'en ai aucune idée ça n'a aucune idée
mais qu'est ce que tu attends faut le
chercher à l'est il est peut-être avec
nous et ce qu'ils ont et zoé qui se
trouve à l'hôpital en face et s'est tue
des enfants elles partent y est j'ai
gagné pas vrai
[Musique]
soum citalis mais société boris becker
et clément des baleines iconix brand et
thomas ouais ouais ok on tue au mind
[Musique]
maintenant à zoé l'année dernière elle
chantait toutes les semaines voyez
l'année dernière et en plus a besoin de
super bien ouais qui votent pour que
malheureusement encore une fois
[Musique]
et cette fermer les yeux
en chambre ni trop qu'il ya une seconde
d'hirvonen
[Musique]
mais trop tard
tu as retrouvé placé sur le côté s'il
vous plaît ne vous est pas fait attendre
je le jure et vous a bien fait pas trop
jaloux le plein alosi premier du pont où
ici pour le jeu je rends visite aux
enfants malades dès que j'ai un peu de
temps libre
j'espère que tu as passé un bon moment
je reviens battoir d'accord bien ça
suffit messieurs s'est terminée musique
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît allez me
faire c'était l'hôpital
alors il est temps d'oublier la règle
numéro 3 on ne m'ont pas sa meilleure
amie
j'en sais rien
j'avoue j'étais amoureuse d'edward dans
twilight arrête les canons du coup je me
suis inscrite à un cours de télépathie
vient à partir de l'écran
vous
[Musique]
c'est trop tard
j'ai bien peur que tu été infectées par
le virus de la boule à facettes attaqué
je devrais t'en débarrasser
on va prouver les garçons tous les
garçons et ensuite ça il faut que j'y
aille c'est de l'argent
oui j'ai vendu ton album de votre but
est malade c'est un album collector de
1963 quoi 50 euros la réponse n'est plus
ensemble
c'est ce qu'ont expliqué
m
tiens regarde ce que j'ai trouvé il est
beau tu trouves pas tu veux essayer
voilà et on se met à jouer ou pas alors
on a fini oui oui oui fils c'est parfait
jeu
je rends visite aux enfants malades des
clubs de temps libre elle est douée
liliane pas vrai maintenant ils savent
tous à quel point tu as un mec généreux
on peut jouer maintenant ça y est t'es
prêt à l'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu l'as pas
jouer je veux savoir ce qui était passé
par la tête qu'est ce qui t'a pris
d'amener ce garçon à l'hôpital
donc la presse débarque il a fait du bon
boulot oui et il a changé du tout au
tout quand il a vu les caméras que ça se
reproduise pas qu'ils cesseraient
prezista en plus c'est pas du tout on
type de garçon tu ne connais pas tous
les artistes sont pareil tu parles on
sûr ça va il est pas peintre écoute tout
ce qui compte pour lui sa petite
personne c'est couru d'avancé
cela te faire du mal alors arrête de
discuter les y est c'est bon merci pour
tes conseils mais moi je suis pas comme
toi et je ferai pas les mêmes erreurs
que toi
bonjour zoé là
oui je te nique oui en six rencontres à
l'hôpital oui désolé si c'est souvent un
peu le bazar quand je vais quelque part
oui mais c'est ce que tu veux de la
tension
je te donne cinq minutes
nick ça va ouais je m'éclate comme tu
peux voir je suis désolé pour hier je ne
savais pas qu'ils allaient venir
ouais et pourtant on a bien profité
c'était naze
c'était parce que je voulais alors
pourquoi tu l'as fait
je vais apporter un truc je déteste les
pandas ouais je crois que j'avais
remarqué ça c'est pour le tlm les pandas
et ça c'est pour toi quoi
[Musique]
tempère c'est un rocker pas vrai
désolé
il nous a laissé tomber pour une fille
qui l'a rencontré il ya quelques
semaines c'est comme ça
des parents ils sont toujours en simple
[Musique]
tu leur parles souvent
non
pourquoi ça
l'important c'est patience va souvent ou
pas je les porte dans mon coeur pour
atteindre le sommet faut faire des
sacrifices
[Musique]
tu pourras aller les voir c'est ce que
je voulais même mais je pars aux états
unis
du coup je les verrai encore moins
hickman ton père
[Musique]
désolé je c'est pas grave
c'est la chanson l'hôpital c'est toi qui
l'a écrite ouais j'ai écrite avec mon
père avant qu'il s'en aille moi aussi il
ya quelques chansons sur lesquelles je
travaille il sort quand cet album jamais
enfin je pense
mon deuxième album a déjà été écrit
synthois ouais c'est liliane qui
s'occupait tôt si je veux cartonné aux
états unis il faut coeur
ça dit qu'on l'a terminée ressemble
heureusement je continue et ce sérieux
quoi c'était super nier d'accord
d'accord
la monnaie unique
[Musique]
ouais voilà vingt deux sources
tu peux arrêter là ouais exact d'accord
car ça m'a paru marie quoi
[Musique]
une évidence en douce notre hôte
c'est rocco faut le faire durer
com
ouais ça le fait mais tu trouvais ça
trop niais
toutfou
allez tous ensemble
eh bien ça allait rejoint new here we
allait très bien maintenant je veux pour
relâcher au visage
[Musique]
une super voix tu devrais en profiter
toi si tu es une super voir
tu devrais arrêter de la gâcher
[Musique]
ouais congo
la maintenance partant numéro
tiens tu es désormais leur propriétaire
de mon numéro
[Musique]
alors c'est une blogueuse une actrice
débutante et si c'est une groupie tu as
oublié celle de l'année dernière
c'est seulement sauvé elle a une voix
magnifique
j'ai chanté avec elle
enfin tout voilà six mois kate nous
attend depuis un moment
kate oui vous allez enregistrer votre
premier diot ton promise you avec kate
tu sais qu'elle a des milliers d'amis
sur instagram de followers en moins de
dix minutes et à 100000 j'aime sur
chacun de ces postes lieu exactement
et toi tu va enregistrer sa première
chanson en anglais c'est génial alors tu
viens il est venu m'apporter le vélo
lui-même c'est trop mignon non il est
roi durable et on a chanté ensemble on
s'est embrassés d'accord simple et là
des arbres harrissart bien sam
oui toi aussi zoé tôt et à l'eau et là
bonjour tu dors encore allez on va te
mettre en place toi tu restes ici tout
le monde est prêt oui d'accord je crois
que ça y est donc musique
des arbres allez allez allez je vais
faire du danger de la menace mais non
c'est quoi cette forêt sam un petit
effort t'es planté là comme un vieux
pots de fleurs ouais tu tanger du danger
ah ah ah voilà et 5 6 7 et 8
les filles c'est une catastrophe
par grands dieux top du top c'est
n'importe quoi
vous vous êtes planté là comme des
idiotes dehors allez aller répéter
ailleurs je suis pas d'humeur
aujourd'hui toi aussi aller dehors on
continue avec la scène suivante 5 30 vo
sam c'est quoi le problème
la règle numéro 2 celle du premier
baiser
ces règles on les a créés quand on était
gamine sam on agrandit maintenant qu'est
ce que tu voulais que je fasse que je
t'envoie un message pour que tu
embrasses le premier venu si non
d'accord peut-être pas mais on était
soit séparé de nos copains avant épi
passé des heures et imaginez notre
premier baiser mme bah désolé que ça se
soit passé autrement en colère à l'epo
[Musique]
encore plus méchant tu peux pas juste
être heureuse pour moi on a chanté tous
les deux ça veut bien dire quelque chose
oui et à ton avis selon toi le commando
de fil à chanter chanter son truc c'est
tout
ça tu étais pas réservés
[Musique]
alors tu sais il y des t'inquiète pas on
n'est pas pressé on a toute la journée
si le et quand elle arrivera on
reprendra tous depuis le début c'est
plus sûr d'accord merci ça quelle bombe
mater sans tuer alors tu es là aussi m
viens on va faire un sale vie pour kate
wars du café dit c'est pas un beau duo
sassi qu'elle était contente oui
j'imagine c'est c'est pour le bloc ah
oui pour les fans wars
m
si vous êtes prêt à vous pourrez écoute
j'ai jamais ressenti un truc pareil
avant peut-être mais en ce moment ce
avec cake les aztèques studio hashtag
projet secret hashtag milk web on l'a
forcé à le faire c'était pas sa décision
ouais c'est vrai qu'il a l'air de
souffrir règle numéro 14 être honnête
même si ça fait mal et règles anti loser
numéro un arrêtez de regarder son
téléphone numéro 2 pas de contacts plus
jamais numéro 3 beaucoup de chocolat
je reviens ici voilà le battre mais pas
encore on va le refaire encore une fois
mais là y'a personne qui croit d'accord
faut que tu m'aides plus de coeur du
doigt pas très aimable est plutôt oui
la formation denis chaumier venir
l'admirer de simple ignorance cabinet
terry tamminen avant cela c'est pas
grave
nick pas de souci on reprend depuis le
début ou ou alors on fait une pause tout
petit
ouais bah c'est pas ma faute c'est clair
trop trop nier et tous ces mouvements
qu'elle fait c'est complètement stupide
mais pourquoi je dois chanter avec elle
ça fait partie du contrat
on s'est mis d'accord et c'est dieu avec
kate est prévu depuis le début tu sais
bien ouais j'en sais rien je sens pas du
tout très bien on arrête pour l'instant
je vais arranger c'est avec franck
pendant ce temps va te reposer
mik mais que ça va aller d'accord
tentant
ça va aller je te le promets
c'est quoi le problème avec mick écoute
si ce duo fonctionne on pourrait
peut-être convaincre franck que ce
nouvel album mériterait peut-être
quelques influences hip hop par exemple
je sais qu'ils y pensent depuis
longtemps et il se trouve que je connais
un excellent rappeur 11 morts mais trop
qu un aîné ce qu'on connaît
nate hoffenheim
[Musique]
un homme honnête
saleh
comment tu vas
ouais
venu
[Musique]
zoé d'accord
ça va je sais ce que tu vas dire donc
perds pas ton temps il part aux états
unis au moins ce sera plus simple comme
ça
il y avait vraiment un truc j'en suis
sûr oui oui je connais bien ce sentiment
je ressentais ce important père
à l'époque si quelqu'un m'avait dit
qu'on finirait par se séparer j'aurais
dit que c'était n'importe quoi moi
j'étais persuadé que notre couple durer
pour toujours
mais parfois les choses changent
ouais
on peut jamais faire confiance à ce
qu'on ressent
c'est un nom elle veut qu'on soit bien
sûr vas-y et s'est amusé d'accord
tout va bien se passer
ça parlait
encore oublié des clés bonjour bonjour
est ce que zoé et là il faudrait que j'y
parle non écoute zoé a assez souffert
comme ça et puis tu pars où ça déjà en
amérique
ta carrière sera toujours plus
importante qu'une qu'une fille que tu
viens tout juste de rencontrer elle me
plait vraiment j'en doute pas vraiment
elle elle est spéciale il jure qu'elle
l'est et toute cette histoire ça la
rendra terriblement malheureuse écoute
se demande de la laisser tranquille
d'accord
mais dans combien de temps vous partez
aux états unis très bientôt il nous
reste encore un concert à donner ici et
ce sera la dernière avant la tournée
américaine
elle vous pressé de partir
nick
oui bien sûr c'est un rêve qui se
réalise règle numéro 1 on passe pas tout
son temps sur son téléphone
règle numéro sept en changer d'idée
alors voyons bridget jones n'oublie
jamais pretty woman love actually entier
trouvait d'almeida mglur2 il est très
drôle
je crois qu'il faut que j'écrive pour
lui dire que c'est terminé
pas la peine je fais quoi bah il a
appelé pendant le répète du théâtre et
si moi qui mets ton portable
oui donc quoi et bat donc j'ai pas
répondu et ensuite je leur ai message
pour dire depuis jamais très peu mais
pourquoi tu as fait ça s'il était
vraiment amoureux de toi pourquoi il
embrassera notre fille tu es qu'il était
triste et qu'il est allé vers quai pour
se consoler j'en sais rien et bien beau
parleur zoé et sans moi tu t'en serai
jamais rendu compte très peu de temps la
règle numéro 12 noeuds jamar est un peu
vite terek débile d'accord c'est pas
pour moi tu l'as fait depuis le début
tout le déteste et jalouse ou quoi
aucune idée de ce que c'est l'amitié
dans une amitié n'y a pas de règle c'est
ridicule sauvé
bien je crois que le moment est venu de
vous présenter un premier extrait du duo
de mick qu'il va chanter ooh côte d'azur
je m'appelle christian vieri je suis
moitié italienne et chanteuse oui ce que
vous allez entendre est une première
ébauche qui sera ensuite retravaillé et
améliorer oui et elle sera ensuite
traduites en anglais et c'est cette
version finale qui apparaîtra ensuite
sur l'album et nous aurons également un
rapport sur nice un battement de coeur
[Musique]
voilà
en ce moment kima emile combes vivant et
volé mes retours de traite est on
pour issa dounia mes marques et lectures
de nights
les manadiers ton en dessous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
comment
d'où elle sort cette chanson elle elle
la grande colère
[Musique]
mais rien est avec elle c'est hors de
question de chanter ensemble en concert
c'est pourquoi ses chansons et non
c'était pas mal a dit qu elle a gâché
toute la chanson écoute mik
je comprends pas trop ce qui vient de se
passer mais je sais que je peux vraiment
pas faire faux bond à franck est ce que
tu te rends compte du nombre de
personnes qui travaillent pour toi pour
produire des chansons et organisait sa
tournée qu'est ce que je suis censé leur
dire qu'ils vont se retrouver au chômage
cette fille en vaut vraiment la peine
champion je viens de publier votre duo
sur youtube il ya déjà eu comme on le
sait pour jouer je comprend le pourquoi
du rap
mik si tu laisses tomber maintenant
alors tu vas tout perdre
tu auras travailler dur pour rien c'est
trop tard de toute façon
bonjour tout le monde
bonjour il sait encore moins à la
princesse rose heroes et aujourd'hui
nous avons partir pour de nouvelles
aventures
mais d'abord je dois aller trouver
quelqu'un mon prince charmant a tout de
suite à l'eau douce
maintien
soupire v22 terre
je lis mais il lui offre
[Musique]
en bas
mais le plein
j'aime à nous le faire
faux rythme m
belle et mécène
[Musique]
den quelques banderilles à dos baignant
l'esp alexis 20e
[Musique]
mm
zoupic ou pas
là
j'ai la manu
m
[Musique]
oui
à
c'est
ça
j'aime another day
[Musique]
e
en
bonsoir
c'est vous qui vendait la guitare c'est
celle qui est là elle est pas tout jeune
[Musique]
j'ai entendu cette chanson à la télé
boule à facettes pas vrai ouais on la
termine ensemble je vois
s'il a le droit de la chanter ce qu'il a
elle doit être spécial moi j'ai pas pu
ouais mais on peut jamais faire
confiance c'est ce qu'on ressent pas
vrai ouais c'est vrai mais
si tu ressens quelque chose
alors tu devrais te battre
oui mais toi tu es parti
ouais
je je pensais que c'était la meilleure
chose à faire
et maintenant je me rends compte que
c'était complètement stupide vous
manquez beaucoup tu sais que la musique
c'est ma vie mais sans vous deux je me
rends compte que je suis rien du tout
aux fans
ce qui est fait est fait j'imagine ouais
ouais ouais
tu vas voir ce garçon
est-ce que c'était le bon s'il était
alors tu dois aller te battre pour lui
mais je veux pas de galipettes avant le
mariage
je plaisante pas tu devrais toujours te
battre pour ce en quoi tu crois n'ai pas
peur de se tromper et souhaitons coeur
tu as du temps en profites en ron
alors maintenant tu vas te mettre un
bonnet des leçons pourrait on dirait
peut-être parce que je suis ton père que
ça te plaise ou non
désormais il est temps de te mettre à la
recherche du calice du crépuscule
nouveau mais il n'y a pas de khalis et
d'après le magicien rouge celle le
calice du crépuscule nouveau pourrait
nous sauver mais il se trouve derrière
le mur de feu dans le royaume interdit
[Musique]
enfin qu'est ce
mais
je vais shu chez le tout dernier dragon
à st de passer au dessus du mur de feu
dont on salue frères c'est carrément de
la bombe moi je te le dis micmacs big
big big bad moi ça c bruni deutsch you
oui d'accord en tout cas un bon morceau
de quoi une seconde coiffard garde mon
morceau ton morceau de quoi je vais
chanter devant des milliers de personnes
c'est dément à djédjé france ne veut
plus de rap finalement je suis désolé
oui je vous écoute trouve moi un regard
de dakar
[Musique]
elles varient
bientôt
[Musique]
tu t'es vue
c'est tout meilleurs à venir c'est
résoudre ce coup que j'étais un peu
jaloux et toutes nos règles sont pas
stupides mais y en a une qui est quand
même important
la règle numéro 1 à tous mes amis pour
toujours aimé ça j'ai pas réussi à vue
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est le pire dans cette
histoire c'est que vous êtes faits l'un
pour l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y aller
et
mce
de l'est
et
j'avais jamais vu comme ça on dirait que
tu brilles petit paris
alors on va le voir c'est moi qui ai
envoyé le message et il eut ce que tu
ressens pour lui c'est votre chanson
vous avez fini de l'écrire ensemble
c'est toi qui doit nous chanter
[Musique]
seulement si tu viens avec moi règle
numéro 5 toques on peut on rester
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais le battre en vélo au violon et
on ira même assez vite parce qu'elle
connaît
[Applaudissements]
la paix dans la remorque effet y aller
[Musique]
sauvé
ma
maman viens avec nous
[Musique]
ceux-là mieux panova
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon merci
il faut qu'on parle à nick wey non c'est
vrai problème les huits entrée sérieuse
et non il coûte témoins madame et chef
de la sécurité
y'a un moment j'étais amoureuse de jack
hichan du coup j'ai pris des cours de
karaté
si vous ne laissez pas entrer je vous
préviens je suis capable de vous mettre
ko en une seule prise
bonsoir oui bonsoir je cherche une place
pour me garer vous vous voyez m'indiquer
où est le parking là bas au coin du
voile sur wii mais je t'avais dit qu'il
se trouvait la latte en parking si t'es
pas content je suis bien mais avant je
me dirai toujours de l'autre côté c'est
pour ça que je voulais essayer ça
coûtait rien mais quoi non mais attendez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment
[Musique]
gr
par la pénombre des grands
[Musique]
nous
les arbres n'ont rien à faire ici
tu m'as volé ma chanson je les ai
écrites avec nick
maintenant c'est notre chanson et il n'y
a plus rien qui puisse faire
écoute certains sont faits pour être
sous les projecteurs et d'autres pour
rester dans l'ombre
tu sais quelle est ta place ciao
qu'est ce que c'est seulement italien
petits connaissent si paris kalyan aussi
coulom ntnu polka piquée six moines au
plo père qu'elle aime titiller ndt et
signala balbi il l'entend je tombe
amoureuse de graziano pellè j'ai pris
quelques cours d'italien
ça m'est égal à eau
ça va pas la tête la suraccumulation jay
jay dégage moi c'est pas le furieuse
elle partie est de nous est de grandes
loges rabat
je le dis ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j
zoé
[Musique]
pardon je vous demande d'accueillir
étape le dire
[Applaudissements]
arrêté le vous pourrez dire adieu à
notre contrat
non
non pas cette fois à l'égal laisse le
faire ses choix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde c'est zoé
heureusement mais trop longtemps
[Musique]
j'arrive jamais manqué pour nous tous
alemanno
on est profond de chercheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exi ouvrière
[Musique]
moussa
exhorte
[Musique]
mais si chaque si elle est douée pas
vrai qu'elle reste peu en ville
qu'est-ce qu'elle a déjà des contres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son timbre
me
et puisque des aînés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
réponse faux
[Musique]
et pour nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
or
[Musique]
est tournée
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai les rap
assorti avec ta tête de bull à face à
[Musique]
you may
est elle assez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui
mais
[Musique]
et fonds marins petra
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]